previously on The Walking Dead well this
is as far as we're going oh hell
whereas next order of business is given
those pills out of the pharmacy huh no I
know if she was a oh it's his brother do
it man
Oh how's it going rez
my name is Perla bot sup girl son he's
not even looking at her so awkward
anyway welcome back to him Walking Dead
I was a tough moment there killing his
brother and all look at that ass but
let's get in here and get this pills oh
[ __ ] this can't be good what what is
that sound
what oh no the zombies they don't like
them good what is she having her back oh
nice what are you gonna do Sam B what
are ya doin so sexy how did they get so
sexy so fast it's literally not being
more than two days how can their flesh
be so are whenever
Oh No doing math I gotta get my dad out
of here I don't plan on Billy galleons
no dilly-dallying uh doc you're bad
enough [ __ ] out doc if I I'm watching
your dog people out of here you got it
Doug Carley and Lee you guys make sure
our defenses stay up till then hi late I
better take that axe in case I run into
any of them on the way to my truck I'll
hold on
[ __ ] you three get on it I'll get back
as fast as I can
oh [ __ ] what am I supposed to do I'm not
glad
guys what's going on here show Charlotte
I love you too man hey I'm not that way
okay shut up doc I'm sorry I don't mean
to be an [ __ ] but seriously oh hey
that hurt [ __ ] up says it doc what oh
snap are you sure
chipper oh he's gonna die dog don't die
I'm sorry
what do it climbing I trust you
oh [ __ ] all right don't worry climbing I
love you anyway so it's you if you don't
shape up oh wow
closer hey alien what is that that's my
dad's cane oh okay good job honey what
that works no dog no [ __ ] him Oh what am
I supposed to do what
but slow-mo moment I love this dog
you're so [ __ ] I'm sorry
seriously that Clemmy save dog or Carnac
oh my god dog is so handsome but I could
get laid but dog is so handsome but I
could get laid but dog play no no I
thank God I can redo that uh sorry all
right I'm sorry dog I actually love you
well make it through this that's right
dog hi all right here we go slum a
moment again I'm sorry I [ __ ] up there
at least I got to fix the dog moment
because I mean it looks like I fed me
and you can't argue with a fad me for
Clemmy she's looking at dog though so
maybe climbing once her but I don't I
did ok it's you sorry sorry dog here you
go girl
um yeah no yeah
shoot em God come on let's go my sesh
man alright oh don't your dad yeah by
yourself I'm a G I can yeah
I carry him up I even open up don't you
dare [ __ ] touch her
you son of a [ __ ] that's right hold on
holy [ __ ] oh my god what do i do what do
i do whatever whatever whatever whatever
okay let's go oh I say them
I'm not get that set up [ __ ] oh he's
going down
hi Barry oh that's right Oh somebody
else kitty oh I trusted that dude you're
a real bro message man free berries [ __ ]
yo that's right
that son of a [ __ ] he touched me I say
he's [ __ ] life why you friended him
what a [ __ ] jerk
what a Jagger Ark I'll kill him
one he's on my death wish list see you
sorry you had to see that climbing you
were strong I got
oh is that that the girl they shot
herself I think so it wasn't awesome
doubt you're [ __ ] sick
that's so sad what is that
Oh their clothes [ __ ]
we strongly be strong you gotta be
strong for Clemmy
I'm Glenn what sorry good
I'm sorry Glenn think I need to go ah
no Stuart look yeah I got friends there
I just can't stay here knowing that they
could be trapped in that city that's not
gonna help
nobody knows what's happening when we
left a few days ago could've gone either
way I gotta take my chances
all right Glenn I understand you do what
you got to do brah
oh wait she knows something about Illini
did she you gotta do what you gotta do
what you gotta do and I gotta do this
respect her you guys be safe from Mike
Glenn I actually like you how many
characters I like in this game except
the mustache man and Clementine but I
like a Glenn not on the gateway or
anything even though we're having an
awkward staring contest here that I won
by the way sayonara Glenn I hope I'll
see you again all right hey all right
now let's beat the shell a lot [ __ ]
fat man where is he
where's that [ __ ] seriously oh where
is he I saw him in the before background
he's over here I know it oh gosh it
close call back there thanks for picking
me up
no problem yeah drew man to take care of
each other yeah yeah we do
hey about Clementine stop yeah earlier I
said there's some stuff out there that
might screw up a precious little girl
like her uh-huh you did well I still
think that's true but after what I saw
today I think between you taking care of
her and her taking care of herself you
two are gonna be just fine thanks thanks
Kenny that means a lot you got it
breakfast
no I god damn it I don't want to talk to
you I know who I want to talk to though
not Carly actually I want to talk to the
fat man I kill him
I'll take her gun I'm okay
you know considering Doug shut up I
can't stop thinking about Doug you
couldn't have seen I mean could we don't
think so pepper died I know it's stupid
we just met and he was such a it's just
that I think that I liked him yay I'm
sorry uh
I'm sorry Carly
it's okay thanks though there's been a
lot of death in the past few days anyway
I'd rather be alone I think all right
Carly
mister I touch my guts understood me
what's up you want my penis what is it
how did you choose we both needed you
you kicked me that's easy you had boobs
he doesn't well he had man boobs I shed
uh I thought you needed to help folks
who needed the help
ah that makes sense but it wasn't a
choice I was just something idea I don't
know why you're right I just wish we
both could have made it you know
same here Ritu curl Amy doc shut up
Clementine doesn't give a [ __ ] about him
back off Hey Oh doc she up the [ __ ] up
he wasn't Oh
daya you want to cool it for me yeah
exactly
sorry hey on you I'm sorry there's not a
lot of kids here no it's not that it's
up Clemmy
I got grabbed again I was there though
I felt in my walkie-talkie pearls ah
then had the other one I'm sorry I'm
sorry
Thanks I know I need to be tough
I'm just don't worry Clemmy know what
doesn't make any sense
I'll get you another one talk to my mom
and dad and now they're gone
it's gone maybe we can try to do another
that's right we'll get you neither one
color I'll just keep this one that I
guess Lee come here for a second
let me go deal with oh he's got
something Jesus guys duck
what are you were like my daughter not
really not really good stay away from
her where everyone here knows that Lee
Everett is a killer I'm not talking
about those things out there you hear me
the deal man
the deals you a question boy hey and
again I wouldn't expect a convicted
murderer to listen to anything anybody's
grieved about is a [ __ ] murderer a
brother I know who you are and I don't
give a [ __ ] about what happens to you
but if anything happens to my daughter
or that little girl you've got with you
you watch your ass oh that's right i
watch your ass hey really good do you
have a second no we should just [ __ ] her
to spite him my dad would be dead if it
weren't for you
that guy Doug is dead because of me you
can't be like that you're only one man
that's right
what's with the change of tune lucky to
have you Lee what's going on Lee you're
scaring me I hope that's the sound of us
winning this thing
winning what me too this motor is pretty
damn defendable we block off the
entrances with some cars keep someone on
watch we could stay here until the
military rolls through I actually agree
with that plan me too
I got bit but we got water and most
importantly we got light your worst
places to call home yeah you're right
it's not gonna be okay it's not gonna be
okay we all know it's like a big a duck
is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] duck probably touched
something god damn it doc to be
continued
all right so that concludes oh we get to
see a little teaser cool clemmy's Mac I
thought would be fun if it's about the
walkers yeah never expected it stopped
us out
I want you to have this okay in case you
or Clementine starts feeling weak I how
are you doing that's the one we gave her
oh we gotta get food Lee soon howdy
I'm Andrew st. John we're from the st.
John dairy
it's beautiful don't repeat what
happened with the waters at Hershel's
farm I hope Seth you choose the kids
this time yeah something's coming Lee
there's gonna be but duck is so annoying
Wow Wow bro place it didn't hit it you
went out of your way to side against him
company
but I don't want to say too much I mean
come on okay come back whoa whoa leave
the zombies talking out there evolving
on this case
ah all right I'll might as well start
episode two right away and I don't see
probably see here lied to Herschel I
actually liked him so I'm a minority
they're the biggest minority actually
who would you save duck or Sean but it's
pretty much 50/50 I can understand that
side with Kenny why wouldn't you side
with Kenny well I decided we Kenny gave
Irene the gun uh I didn't do it okay
most people did it in the dogger Carly
yeah everyone chooses Carly it's only
girls who choose me other one I don't
know hey that was pretty epic I guess I
don't have this going in the background
like I said I'll probably start the the
next up is a right way hope you bros are
enjoying this let's play I'm seeing a
lot of great feedback on like I'm
enjoying it a lot it's a lot of fun and
like I said it was definitely what I was
looking for something
horror sorry a story with a horror twist
at least you know as so definitely
looking forward to all five episodes
there's two more hours right now I think
they come like each month or something
like that but anyway thanks for all the
support Bros it really means a lot like
affairs if you enjoyed scrag him a bread
today and I'll see you next time ciao
know why I bother bad right
alright the other one
no no no no don't die don't die don't
die tonight please I'll do it